hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer a question
from tomorrow's one of my newsletter
readers who wants to put on a music
festival as his business and it's had a
hard time raising capital for to get the
sponsors to help them launch it and one
of my advice on how to how to get that
thing going so a couple things if you
are going after sponsorship they want to
see that you have something it's really
hard to go out their businesses to say
hey I'd like you to sponsor me and give
me whatever it is five hundred bucks ten
thousand dollars whatever it is that you
need from them when there's nothing for
them to look at beyond just an idea so
you want to build up momentum so what I
would do with you you're starting up its
movement around youth especially with a
with a music concert is kick up a lot of
noise in social media so build a Twitter
following build a facebook following
talk with what you want to do get people
excited about it get people come into
your site and interacting you want to
build up as much momentum as you can as
possible to get it going start a
newsletter create a YouTube channel if
you need to try to get people organized
in some way so if you have a flash mob
or something to get on the media's
attention as well just to start building
some momentum so you're not an unknown
quantity if you're not going to a
business say hey I have an idea it's
just on paper and there's nothing to
back you up you have also mentum if you
can see you have thousands of people
following you on facebook and twitter
and on your newsletter that you can
access you know right away that's an
opportunity that businesses would jump
on so first take that time to build up a
following build up an audience through
social media through your newsletter etc
the next thing I would do is when you're
going after your first sponsors try to
go for in-kind partnerships and that's a
lot easier to get in kind donations
instead of money up front so just depend
on what you need for your for your event
I'm sure there's a whole bunch of stuff
that you'll need that you would use the
money to go and buy you might be able to
get those guys to be able to give you
that amount of dollars but not in money
but in actual products or services so
think about all the products and
services you need to spend to get this
event going talk to those companies and
see if they'd be willing to donate some
of their time or some other products or
prize
is to be able to you know promote
themselves out the event it's a lot easy
for a company to give up some of their
inventory or to give up some of their
service time that they may have extra
time anyway with their company instead
of giving you cash right and that can be
your lead-in nobody needs to know that
they're they're only given you you know
in-kind donations but you can start
raising a lot of you know dollar value
items for the event so you can say you
know you've raised $50,000 or whatever
it is because you have you know in-kind
products or services so that's kind of
step one then you can use that to go
after other businesses you can say well
we've already partnered up with these
companies and we've already got all this
attention happening on social media and
on our newsletter and some you know many
many events that you've done that starts
building the momentum so now when you go
in you're talking to companies you have
a lot behind you and it feels like
they're going to be missing out if they
don't join on the boat it's a lot better
than just going in with a piece of paper
and saying here's an idea we have but we
don't have any traction so that's what I
encourage you to do and this applies for
anything your business you know when
companies pitched us about raising
capital before if they just came in with
an idea they usually got to know but
they came in with some momentum
they came with you know a product and
they had a few customers and people
willing to buy or they had a Board of
Directors or Board of Advisors you know
anything to show that this is something
that is interesting because people get
pitched all the time right the companies
that you're going after they're getting
pitched all the time for donations in
kind and also no dollars and it's hard
to figure out who to go with or not so
if you're the one guy who comes in with
a whole bunch of traction behind you a
whole bunch of media and an online
attention and you already have some
other partners then it's a lot easier
for somebody to say yes and pick you
instead of everybody else who's pitching
them as well so I hope that helps if you
guys liked the video please give it a
thumbs up below makes me want to make
more of these videos for you and I love
to hear you have to think if you own
leave a comment or the video or if you
have a question you can leave it in the
comments as well and we'll see you on
the next episode
you
you